Hey guys this is another video request
on premature gray hair! So you got a few
great hair, you look at it, look at
yourself in the mirror and you're like
man I'm not that old! You're scared
because you feel like you're looking
older than what you really are,
right? But what is the average age that
men go gray? Well Caucasians mostly go
gray in their mid-thirties. Asians in their
late thirties and African-Americans in
their mid 40's. So the bad news is yes
most of us will have a lot of gray hair
in our 50's all right but a lot of us get
gray hair prematurely and you're
wondering like what can you do about it?
Well the bad news is it mostly depends
on your genes, but that being said
there's also a few external factors, a
few things that you can control and
that's what I'm gonna talk about in this
video. So let's not waste any more time
let's get right into the video:
hey this is your first time here
on my channel, welcome! I'm Daniel.
Consider subscribing & also clicking the
notification bell so you won't miss any
of the next videos. I do anything
about style grooming fitness and life
itself. Now to know how to prevent
premature gray hair you need to know
what causes it, right? So that you can
prevent it. So I'm gonna tell you what
causes it and also how you can prevent
it. So let's start with the first one:
certain medical conditions
There's certain medical conditions that causes you to go gray quicker. Conditions like
thyroid disease or certain rare
inherited tumor conditions also certain
autoimmune diseases like alopecia and
others. So how do you handle that?
We, I'm not a doctor so I can't help you in
this one all I can say is go see your
doctor about this. Let's move on to the
next one
another cause of premature gray hair
might be because you don't have enough
vitamin b12 in your body this is a
bigger problem especially for a
vegetarian or if you're a vegan because
plant foods don't have vitamin b12
unless they are fortified. So there's two
ways you can get more vitamin b12: By
eating the right foods and also
supplements. So what kind of foods
contains vitamin b12? Beef liver and
clams are the best sources but you can
also eat food like fish, meat, poultry,
eggs, milk and other dairy products as
well. You can also get it from
supplements like the vitamin b12
supplements from Jarrow.
I've added it for you in the video
description so you can go and check it
out. Let's move on to the next one
Stress! Now there's a lot of different
opinions on stress and what influence it
has on gray hair and I've done a lot of
research on this but I believe that
stress doesn't make your hair go gray
directly but it can cause the condition
for you to lose your hair three times
faster and when it grows back it can
grow back gray.
Smoking! Now there's been
a lot of studies on smoking and it's
shown that guys are actually two and a
half times more likely to go gray faster
than guys who do not smoke. Listen very
carefully, I'm not saying that you will
for sure go grey quicker. I'm just saying
that it's two and a half times more
likely. It's also interesting that
smoking can cause that grey hair to look
yellow, you will see that a lot. So how do you stop it? Stop smoking...
So what can you do about the hair that's
already gray? Well it's only three things:
Number one is you accept it and you embrace it.
Number two, you dye your hair. Or
number three you shave it all off.
But if you dye it or if you shave it, it's just gonna grow back gray again.
I'm already starting to have some gray hair here in in the sides of my hair
and I can see it, but I embrace it. I like it. I accept it.
I think we worry too much about scars and wrinkles and gray hair, because when you look at your life
Wrinkles mean that you've laughed.
Gray hair means that you cared and
scars means that you lived...
If you liked the video, give it a thumbs up subscribe and
I'll see you in the next video
cheers guys